Ronaldo, Messi and Zlatan are warming up
before an ALL STARS football game
Ronaldo gets the ball, and passes it to Zlatan
Zlatan then passes the ball to Messi…
And then Messi passes the ball back to Zlatan
and many such passes are exchanged.
Now it was pretty easy for me to explain this to you diagrammatically.
But what if I wanted to explain this to a COMPUTER?
The computer will not understand diagrams.
So we make a small table on the right with 3 rows and 3 columns.
We can have Ronaldo, Messi and Zlatan as rows.
And to know ‘who the ball was passed to’,
we have Ronaldo, Messi and Zlatan as columns.
We all know what Zlatan is capable of
but let’s assume the players can’t pass the ball to themselves.
So these three elements will be zero.
There is ONE arrow going from R towards M.
So we write a one here.
And there’s just one pass from Ronaldo to Zlatan.
Similarly we fill the rest of the slots.
What we see here is nothing but a MATRIX.
It is nothing but an ARRAY of elements…
something which a computer can decode!
And it summarizes the entire warm up session.
Adding up all the numbers here will give us the total number of passes.
And it also tells us the DIRECTION of the passes!
Don’t you wish matrices were taught like this in school?